hi my name is Rajiv Sangma lares I'm the
president of alcatel-lucent in Asia and
I'm the chairman of the Global Agenda
Council on ICT this morning we organized
a discussion panel session on the
infrastructure imperative in Asia it was
a lively discussion six participants a
lot of issues covered and at the end of
the session the conclusion was we've
made extraordinary progress in building
both the hard infrastructure in ASEAN
and the soft infrastructure but there
are some very real issues and
bottlenecks around governance around
corruption transparency and financing
having said that the takeaway of all the
panelists was that relative to other
parts of the world the ASEAN region is
one that is moving more quickly and has
more opportunities relative to other
parts of the world so there was a good
news aspect to this discussion and it
was a very productive discussion